thiers d'expulsion troisième pacte pour
l'emploi
ils concernent davantage de catégorie
professionnelle mais c'est bon soir un
frisson a parcouru les ailes de
l'aviation française pendant trois
heures hier soir nous venions de vous
apprendre que l'airbus était
officiellement interdits de vol aux
états unis ainsi en avait décidé de
l'agencé fédérale de l'aviation
américaine qui voulait tirer les leçons
de l'accident de chicago 273 morts elle
avait déjà interdit de vol le dc10 s
attaquer donc à l'avion européen et puis
quelques heures plus tard changement de
cap
mille excuses disent les américains nous
nous sommes trompés c'était une gaffe un
malentendu l'airbus n'a rien à craindre
germain égaux nous raconte la sphère
l'instant où l'avenir d'airbus a failli
être hypothéqué sur le territoire
américain et où sa carrière commerciale
dans le monde aurait pu être gravement
compromise en annonçant conjointement
l'interdiction des vols de dc 10 et
d'airbus aux états unis l'un des
responsables de l'agencé fédérale de
l'aviation civile américaine faisait une
grave confusion
s'il est exact que les réacteurs
d'airbus sont les mêmes que ceux
utilisés par le dc10 s'il est vrai aussi
que la nacelle c'est à dire la
carrosserie de ses réacteurs ont été
étudiés par mcdonnell douglas ce n'est
en revanche pas le cas du pylône qui
relie le réacteur à l' aile de l'avion
or ce sont ces points de fixation qui
ont lâché sur le dc10 qui s'est écrasé à
chicago une confusion tout de même un
peu légère de la part d'un organisme
aussi sérieux important que l' agence
fédérale américaine
si elle a été levée pour airbus
l'interdiction de vol a été maintenu
pour les décès disent qu'ils n'ont pas
encore été révisée une décision
catastrophique pour le constructeur
mcdonnell douglas tous les appareils de
ce type sont en effet depuis hier soir
cloués au sol pour des vérifications
très approfondie à l'heure actuelle 274
dc10 sont en service dans le monde
les pertes risque d'être lourde pour les
compagnies qui les utilisent quant aux
débris de celui qui s'est écrasé il ya
cinq jours et sont soigneusement
examinées en laboratoire
on s'étonne cependant que la décision
concernant airbus et pu être prises
aussi rapidement son succès des flairé
fils outre atlantique est encore en
mémoire l'accueil fait par les
américains au supersonique concorde la
dispersion nautique française doit aussi
apprendre à se méfier de certains coups
bas qui risquerait de la mettre en péril
oui
j'ajoute que ses dc10 american dont vous
parlez géré amerigo pourrait recommencer
à voler dès mercredi quant à la
compagnie française duty à qui vous le
savez en utilise quelques-uns elle a
déjà repris ses vols réguliers
aucune anomalie n'a été décelée par ces
contrôleurs avaient côté donc joël le
theule milices des transports première
question celle que nous posions gaffe
coucou bas de l'appareil des mecs à
écouter souriant aimable disons gaffe
mais elle est tout de même surprenante
et c'est le sentiment que comme beaucoup
de français j'ai ressenti en même temps
j'ai été très choqué en effet il n'y
avait pas d'analogie possible entre le
dc10 et l'airbus
ce sont des avions de conception
différente de constructeurs différents
et ce qui s'était passé sur un dc10 ne
pouvait pas se passer sur l'airbus
ou alors il fallait poser tout le
problème des avions gros porteurs qui
ont des moteurs sous leur voilure
alors pourquoi ne pas parler du boeing
747 pourquoi ne pas parler du look id
tristar la décision paraît c'est
inacceptable et surtout il admissible
qu'on ne prendrait pas de décision à la
légère on peut-être parler de gaz
calculés à leur nom
écoutez
le monsieur bond qui a pris cette
décision répondait à des questions je
pense qu'il ne s'agit que d'une erreur
elle est énorme
et comme la fda est un organisme
extrêmement respectée c'est une part de
son autorité qui en prend un coup
on a eu un petit peu la puce à l'oreille
avec l'histoire du concorde de la new
york puis à washington
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut être
dangereux pour l'avenir pour l'avion de
concorde et d'airbus là-bas sur cet
immense marché américain a je pense que
non la concurrence est une chose la
loyauté en est une autre
alors en matière de concurrence il est
normal qu'une le succès d'airbus dérange
néanmoins les américains ne
comprendraient pas que l'on utilise des
moyens déloyaux pour abattre un
concurrent et je ne pense pas que cet
été l'objectif poursuivi par les
responsables de l'agencé américaine ne
peut pas mettre en cause le contrat avec
l'as twr par exemple écouter kg et il
est en cours de discussion aucune
décision n'est prise on reproche un
petit peu à airbus qui marchent bien en
ce moment on lit suffisamment souvent
d'avoir un petit peu de mal a fourni en
maintenant bientôt vous allez peut-être
être rattrapé par les américains qui ont
réparé un boeing 737 pour un an et demi
à peu près des lieux sont prêts à
fournir
elle ajouté il y a un nom il y avait peu
de personnes qui croyaient à l'airbus
est la question qui mettait souvent
posée cda qu'il vendrait vous maintenant
on me dit puisqu'on le vent a même vendu
plus de 350 exemplaires
mais comment va-t-on de construire et on
me dit les américains eux sont prêts ils
n'ont pas sorti un seul pour le moment
donc je confiance des industriels de
l'europe pour s'organiser et faire face
à l'augmentation de cadence car il ya
déjà 60 70 avions qui volent et
l'accroissement de la cadence de
production est réel tomassi deuxième
titre de l'actualité ce soir le nouveau
projet de loi sur les travailleurs
immigrés adopté cette nuit par les
députés un texte qui en gros et en les
pouvoirs de la police en cas d'expulsion
nous allons détailler dans l'instant
mais sachez d'ores et déjà qu'il
provoque quelques remous dans les
milieux politiques à gauche chez les
syndicats cgt cfdt c'est un projet d'une
extrême gravité a dit par exemple
georges séguy au mrap le mouvement
contre le racisme et pour l'amitié entre
les peuples et même dans l'église c'est
le cas de l'archevêque de rennes et 2,2
pasteur de la même ville
alors pour mieux comprendre cette levée
de boucliers des payons donc ce projet
qui je vous le rappelle peut encore être
amendé au sénat quatre millions 200
mille étrangers vivent actuellement en
france et tous les jours soit cent mille
personnes entrent ou sortent de france
dans cette population étrangère ce sont
les portugais les plus nombreux ils sont
suivis par les algériens italiens les
espagnols les marocains et les tunisiens
en forte majorité du travail dans la
construction automobile le bâtiment et
les travaux publics selon le ministre
l'intérieur ce projet de loi ne concerne
dans cette population que les étrangers
en situation irrégulière ils sont
évalués à 3 ou 400 mille personnes donc
environ un résident étranger sur 10 ce
texte s'il était adopté modifierait la
loi actuelle sur 3.1 les conditions
d'entrée en france 2 les motifs
d'expulsion 3 l'exécution des décisions
d'expulsion
l'entrée en france pourrait être refusée
à tout étranger qui constitue une menace
pour l'ordre public
les opposants à ce texte souligne que
cette formulation est dangereuse car
trop vague
un second cas de refus était proposée
par les auteurs du texte il voulait
subordonner l'entrée en france
à la condition que l'étranger possède
des moyens d'existence suffisants
cette clause n'a pas été voté par les
députés second point les motifs
d'expulsion ils sont au nombre de six
dont trois principaux
si la présence de l'étranger est une
menace à l'ordre public
si le titre de séjour est faux six
étrangers rester en france alors que sa
carte de séjour n'a pas été renouvelé
c'est ce dernier point qui suscite le
plus de controverse car il laisse planer
une menace sur l'ensemble étrangers qui
vit en france
enfin dernier point les conditions
d'expulsion serait simplifié le
permettrait à l'administration de saisir
directement la force publique pour faire
reconduire un étranger à la frontière
c'est étrange et pourrait dans ce cas
être entendu par une commission spéciale
enfin les étrangers qui seraient refoulé
pour ces différentes raisons pourraient
être maintenus dans les locaux
administratifs
nous avons parlé tout à l'heure de
racisme bien tout à l'heure à l'issue du
conseil des ministres le chef de l'état
s'est entretenu avec le miz la justice
de la mort de deux sénégalais la semaine
dernière à orange
je suis profondément ému at il pris dans
la république il faut que la justice
établisse clairement les responsabilités
réponse d'alain peyrefitte quatre
personnes ont déjà été inculpées et
placées sous mandat de dépôt tout cela
donc qu'à l'issue d'un conseil des
ministres qui avaient décidé d'augmenter
le traitement des fonctionnaires de 2,75
pour cent à partir du 1er juin
et aussi d'entériner le troisième parc
pour l'emploi des jeunes dont je vous
parlais juillet un pacte qui lui entrera
en vigueur le 1er juillet et qui devrait
intéresser un peu plus de quatre cent
mille jeunes
une manière de synthèse entre les deux
précédents pacte le premier généralement
considéré comme un succès et le second
comme un demi succès ou un demi échec
comme on voudra donc ce soir le
troisième un troisième pacte pour
l'emploi des jeunes va durer trois ans
et non pas un an
comme les deux premiers il sera élargi
aux chômeurs de plus de 45 ans demandeur
d'emploi depuis un an et aux fans seul
depuis six ans
voici les deux principales nouveautés de
3e pacte dont l'esprit est de développer
les mesures qui ont donné satisfaction
précédemment l'exonération des charges
sociales et fixé à 50% pendant un an
pour toute personne définitivement
embauché exonération totale pour les
apprentis prime de 5000 francs pour les
artisans seul qui embauchent
on revient donc au voeu du cnpf très
proche des mesures du premier pacte les
stages pratiques en entreprises ne
seront plus uniquement réservé aux
travailleurs manuels et là encore on
revient aux dispositions du premier
pacte enfin poursuite des stages
formations et contrat emploi formation
des succès coût de ce pacte 3 milliards
et demi de francs
le prolongement sur trois ans ce nouveau
pacte est ce que ça veut dire que vous
ne prévoyez pas d'amélioration de la
situation du chômage
cela veut dire en réalité que la vague
démographique qui est de 750 mille
jeunes qui arrivent tous les ans sur le
marché du travail va se prolonger au
delà de 1985 et qu'il faut désormais
répondre à ce problème de l'emploi au
niveau des entreprises en prévoyant pour
les envoyer un plan de charge
suffisamment étalé sur le temps pour
qu'ils puissent recruter former les
jeunes et responsive au problème avec
lequel sera confronté durablement notre
pays mais ce que l'éducation nationale
ne pourrait pas prendre en charge elle
est en acier alors cela l'éducation
nationale c'est un problème qu'on
regarde mesure de la ddt et monsieur
legendre et moi même nous allons déposer
un projet de loi ou soumettre un projet
de loi d'abord au niveau du gouvernement
plus haut niveau parlement sur la
formation professionnelle en alternance
qui a précisément pour objet de recycler
de former des jeunes sortant du système
scolaire pour un enseignement
professionnel
le conseil des ministres a également
adopté diverses mesures destinées à
faciliter l'embauché de salariés
supplémentaires dans l'artisanat et puis
en a reparlé sans plus de précision de
la réforme de l'indemnisation du chômage
et de l'amélioration de l'agencé
nationale pour l'emploi
et puis pendant ce temps une négociation
importante reprenait cet après midi
entre patronat et syndicats la durée du
travail
vous savez peut-être que la sphère avait
été mal engagée l'année dernière mais il
semble aujourd'hui que les points de vue
soient un petit peu rapproché et il
n'est pas impossible comme arrive à un
accord cadre à l'automne évidemment on a
tendance à regarder du côté de
l'entreprise de pointe celles qui
pratiquent déjà des expériences dans
l'aménagement du temps de travail
est ce d'ailleurs en marge de l'actuelle
législation transportons nour à quimper
pour une expérience de ce genre radio
cope par l'enjeu le matin les indices à
larié de cette usine de vêtements pointe
à 8 heures le soir elles partent à 5h30
ayant accompli une demi heure de plus
que les 8 heures réglementaires
ces heures supplémentaires ne sont pas
payées elles servent à cumuler trois
semaines de plus de congés payés ce qui
fait tant pis cette semaine par an 6
l'été une l'hiver
ce système fonctionne depuis six ans il
a été accepté dès le début par un vote
des salariés à la majorité des trois
quarts mais c'est un peu par hasard que
l'idée en est venu aux patrons de lusine
monsieur là nous et pourtant je vais
travailler j'ai travaillé jour et nuit
par semaine
et au lieu de 5 jours et la demie
et que je faisais en supplément gelard
forte j'ajoutais à mes vacances d'été il
fait que je prenais système et à ce
monde mais en cô j'étais encore en
vacances et je voyais ces dames
reprendre le travail qu'un jour avant
moi j'avais mauvaise conscience et je me
suis dit il faut que je trouve quelque
chose pour que tout le monde bénéficie
les six semaines thierry quand on a voté
pour les sept semaines ce type d'accord
non pourquoi je jouais c'était un
avantage du patron de trouver punir à 5
heures c'était super bien et mélenchon
vient répondre avec en arrière-fond fait
les enfants donc
passé six semaines avec le cdd
mazeau contente oui
est ce que c'est une grande souplesse
regarder
ah oui
patron de la venue à la réunion
mieux il y a deux ans le directeur a
reçu une lettre anonyme qui mettait en
cause le système des vacances l'argument
essentiel
nous avons un mois et demi de vacances
en effet mais que faire avec notre
maigre salaire de toute manière à la
rentrée bien avant nous sommes couchés
j'y réfléchis un peu à ça je vous dirais
deux choses la première c'est qu'on est
dans une région où les flashs c'est à 15
km et donc pas loin et deuxième homme
que pour cette partie pezens côte d'azur
ou ailleurs ils sont ce qu'elles sont
rendus sur place elles qu'elles ont déjà
acheté l'équipement de vacances le
prolongement des vacances n'est pas une
dépense supplémentaire au passé vous les
vacances cet été
ni d'un camping selouane caper non 17 km
vous n'avez jamais plus loin
de plus les enfants sont nés non les
trois semaines de plus c'est important
pour vous oui sûrement
faisant du pays la garde d'enfants la
parra continue transport pis donc on
gagnait tous connus et pour vous parler
de raisons d'argent là et si on vous
payez plus cher votre salaire on va au
monde même en février on perdre et qu'en
même temps nous nous sommes donnés en
heures supplémentaires ça nous fait que
200 francs et lagarde a continé
transport d'un peu plus de 100 pendant
les trois semaines
donc finalement vous êtes gagnante comme
cette intro gp gagnante et les payer les
heures supplémentaires en congé ce n'est
pas légal
en principe ils doivent être payé en
salaire avec une majoration de 25%
l'inspection du travail a pourtant
laissé faire l'inspection du travail
n'ignore pas cette situation et tolèrent
cette expérience parce que cette
expérience à l'accord de la plus grande
partie du personnel et qu'elle présente
un caractère original d'une idée qui
mérite d'être explorée étudiés est ce
que vous pensez qu'il faudrait un jour
modifier la législation du travail pour
admettre ce genre d'expérience la
législation sur la durée du travail est
une législation bien ancienne mais la
réglementation se modifie
perpétuellement soit dans le cadre de la
loi soit dans le cadre des négociations
entre les partenaires sociaux et cette
expérience est peut-être aujourd'hui en
avant c'est peut-être préfigure-t-elle
la négociation gros à l'instant des
brésiliens justement sur cette première
réunion cnpf syndicats qui viennent de
s'achever les deux parties se reverront
le 18 juin puis en septembre il semble
que le cnpf fait de nouvelles
propositions en acceptant en particulier
de discuter en priorité et non plus de
l'aménagement mais vraiment de la
réduction du temps de travail
et puis une petite parenthèse avant
d'aborder le gros dossier européen une
parenthèse justice la cour d'appel de
paris a confirmé aujourd'hui le maintien
en liberté de cinq prévenus donc
l'europe avec tout d'abord le tout
dernier sondage sur les élections du 10
juin un sondage qui paraîtra demain dans
le figaro et qui a été réalisé par la
sofres ont lendemain de la cogner dur
servan-schreiber ça veut dire entre les
24 et 26 mai lors jacques servan
shreiber réalise 3 % des suffrages mais
curieusement cela ne gêne pas la liste
de simone veil qui elle fait un point de
plus 30% des intentions de vote
celle de jacques chirac ces deux points
de moins il est à 16 % la liste de
françois mitterrand perd un point il est
à 26 % et celle de georges marchais en
gagne 1 le pc donc à 20% s'agit là du
dernier sondage du figaro ensuite la loi
interdit
leur parution à partir de dimanche pour
le reste je vais essayer de vous
épargner les déclarations des uns et des
autres la campagne officielle est là
pour ça mais je pourrais vous donner une
vision plus concrète des choses avec ce
regard des agriculteurs sur l'europe un
regard à multiples facettes saisie par
alain douguet ski christian baron 27 ans
il fait du port plus exactement il est
né soeur engraisseurs il a 65 truies en
production c'est un producteur moyen la
nuit lorsqu'une pluie mais bah il est
dans la porcherie et surveille car
chaque pour celui qui arrive c'est un
peu d'argent et il faut rembourser les
emprunts bâtiment matériels
il est hostile au marché commun d'école
pour lui c'est l'inégalité la
concurrence malgré la récente révision
des montants compensatoires avec le
système des montants compensatoires qui
sont en faveur de l'allemagne de la
hollande
ces deux pays perçoivent une subvention
pour exporter du port en france mais en
parlant d'alimentation on peut quand
même soulevé le problème qui est celui
du manioc
les hollandais se permettent avec le
manioc de l'utiliser en grande quantité
dans leur alimentation
et quand on sait aussi que le manioc ne
passe pas par le régime de la communauté
je crois que là encore c'est tout à fait
saine certains pays européens ne
respectant pas les règlements
communautaires achète à des pays hors
marché commun des aliments moins cher
manioc de thaïlande ou soja américain
pendant ce temps la france nourrit ses
ports avec sa propre production
céréalière d'un prix de revient plus
élevé autres dangers redoutés
principalement par les agriculteurs du
sud-ouest la concurrence grec bientôt
espagnole et portugaise elle est
redoutable affirment les producteurs de
fruits et légumes pour ces derniers il
n'est pas question d'alimentation comme
pour les éleveurs mais de main d'oeuvre
or son coût est beaucoup plus élevé en
france que dans les autres pays
méditerranéens
voici par exemple dans quelles
conditions travaillent les ouvriers
espagnols
les patrons de dans le village sur la
place du village
ils se choisissent les ouvriers et les
ouvriers évidemment sont bien contents
de trouver du travail
dimanche dernier j'étais en espagne dans
une espérance d'une exploitation de 6
hectares de légumes à particuliers en
particulier de rupture vous les ouvriers
le dimanche matin préparez les machines
pour le lundi matin
ou bien c'est à dire qu'ils n'étaient
pas payés et j'étais bien content de
pouvoir commencer lundi matin
jean paul fourchon 25 ans producteur de
lait il a 50 vaches laitières 40
génisses il fait 5 à 7 cents litres de
lait par jour production légèrement
supérieur à la moyenne régionale
malgré quelques réserves pour lui le
repas et écoles c'est un avantage pas de
problème de débouchés de plus il existe
un prix minimum de la garantie pour nous
producteurs de lait la menteuse des
trains intérieurs de la communauté
économique européenne c'est d'avoir un
débouché assurée et un meilleur cours
par rapport au coût mondial qui se
trouve plus bas que le courtier alors
déboucher faire que vous ne pourriez pas
vous que votre production de nature non
ces salles en bretagne on est on sûr
produit par rapport à d'autres régions
et donc la consommation ne se trouve pas
sur place donc on est bien obligés
d'aller chez nos voisins européens donc
de sérieux avantages mais aussi des
inconvénients
les montants compensatoires appliquée au
lait n'ont pas disparu ils ont
simplement été diminuée de moitié ce qui
fait que le lait est payé 1 française
aux producteurs français mais un franc
39 aux allemands et un franc 28 ou
hollande
sylviane dit jean-luc basset 24 ans il
travaille en groupement d'exploitation
commun avec son père et sa mère
il fait du lait du port du lapin pour ce
type familial l'exploitation l'europe
agricole c'est plutôt positif
jean-luc travail avec une coopérative
c'est en quelque sorte son assistance
technique son service commercial
sa liaison entre les marchés agricoles
et l'exploitation familiale
cette formule correspond en général le
mieux aux aspirations des agriculteurs
france c'est la structure d'exploitation
qui leur permet le mieux de s'exprimer
et de faire d'avoir une exploitation à
leur dimension qui va permettre d'être
pleinement responsable de leur travail
est-ce que l'organisation européenne de
l'agriculture telle qu'elle existe
fabrice maintient votre ville à la
culture familiale sous bruxelles par le
biais de certains textes qui régissent
entre autres des plans de développement
permet l'obtention de prêts dans le
cadre plan développement par exemple
pour une production donnée c'est un
quota de financement pour une production
donnée qui favorise temps bien images
disons l'exploitation familiale
les deux tiers des exploitations
agricoles françaises se font vers
l'europe dès 9 1 cours de 40 à 50%
supérieur au cours mondial c'est donc
capital mais il reste beaucoup à faire
entre autres régler définitivement le
problème viticole revoir les productions
hors sol prévoir une réglementation des
marchés méditerranéens deuxième fois
maintenant de l'information sur l'europe
antenne 2 à lexique le plus complet
possible sur les institutions de la
communauté aujourd'hui les 9 et le
tiers-monde la convention de lomé
jean-michel mercurol dès l'origine
l'europe montre l'intérêt qu'elle porte
au développement des pays du tiers-monde
à commencer bien sûr par l'afrique
héritage du passé colonial de certains
états fondateurs le traité de rome en 57
stipulé déjà l'association de la
communauté avec les pays et territoires
d'outre-mer mais l'indépendance de ces
pays conduit bientôt à négocier une
nouvelle convention les accords de
yaoundé qui consacre la libre
circulation des marchandises entre les
six et dix sept états africains
à côté du libre accès au marché
communautaire l'instrument le plus
important de la coopération sera le
fonds européen de développement
c'est à dire des dons qui permettent la
réalisation d'équipements et le
financement d'une infrastructure agro
industrielle dans les pays associés
mais l'entrée de la grande-bretagne dans
le marché commun élargi encore le champ
de la coopération avec le tiers-monde
aux anciens partenaires d'afrique se
joignent de nombreux états des caraïbes
et du pacifique
la convention de lomé signé en 75 par 46
pays sur la base d'une égalité complète
entre partenaires elle assure aux pays
en voie de développement un prix
d'exportation garantie et un marché pour
leurs matières premières depuis les 46
sont devenus 57 et la convention de lomé
qui arrive à expiration est déjà en
cours de renégociation
elle concerne 285 millions d'habitants
des pays en voie de développement mais
sont encore exclus de son champ d'action
les quatre pays d'asie du sud où vit la
population la plus pauvre du monde vous
légion dans l'antenne 2010 les
américains ont décidé de subventionner
les importations de pétrole vers les
états unis autrement dit inciter les
producteurs à vous non à vendre aux
américains plutôt qu'ailleurs donc une
mauvaise affaire pour les européens est
à l'instant même le gouvernement
français viennent de réagir par la
bouche dans deux régions qui fait une
déclaration estimant virulente contre
cette mesure unilatérale américaine
cette décision est très grave dit il
elle ne fera que accentue le désordre du
marché pétrolier et l'envolée des prix
monsieur giraud par après demain pour
les états unis en iran de violents
affrontements ont fait 80 morts à
khoramshahr c'est un port pétrolier
situé environ à 700 km de téhéran
on ne connaît pas encore exactement les
raisons de ces affrontements qui ont
opposé essentiellement les unités de la
marine et des habitants de la minorité
arabe de la ville dans la soirée on
apprenait que ces combats s'étendaient à
la ville d'aba dans ce trou vous savez
la principale raffinerie de pétrole de
l'iran ont salvador toujours la violence
le chargé d'affaires suisse a été
assassiné par un homme qui a réussi à
prendre la fuite
leonid brejnev est arrivé aujourd'hui à
budapest cette visite officielle de
trois jours du numéro un soviétique en
ombrie semble prouver que son état de
santé s'améliore
il sera donc présent à vienne le 15 juin
pour la signature des accords salt avec
les américains pakistan nous vous
annoncions hier la libération à mme
buteau
et bien la veuve de l'ancien premier
ministre a aussitôt annoncé qu'elle
serait candidate au poste du
de premier ministre en vue des élections
qui se dérouleront dans six mois à paris
ce matin échange de coups de feu entre
malfaiteurs et policiers trois voleurs
de venait de commettre un hold up dans
le xviiie arrondissement
les policiers étaient là une fusillade
éclate et l'un des voleurs est mort les
deux autres blessés et puis à brec'h
dans les côtes du nord quatre hommes qui
sont présentées comme membres du flb ont
fait sauter la maison du commissaire le
taillan terre qui est patron du srpj de
rennes
j'aurai maintenant au sport avec la
troisième journée des internationaux de
france de tennis florentaise battu na
stade en quatre sets dominguez perd face
aux tchèques lendl borg après beaucoup
de difficultés a fini par s'imposer face
à l'américain tom dixon en quatre sets
les images de cette rencontre
généralement lorsque bord joue c'est lui
que le public regarde et applaudi
aujourd'hui surprise et c'est une
première les faveurs de la foule sont
allés à son adversaire l'américain tom
dixon borg est certainement mal remis de
son élongation à la cuisse il a déclaré
je ne souffre plus mais n'a pas
convaincu
deux indices une balle lente un jeu de
jambes émoussé cela dit l'habitude
peut-être bernburg a tout de même
remporté son seul et en quatre sets bien
difficile sur le central de
roland-garros et dans une atmosphère
très lourd oui bord glace tu as tout le
monde connaît ces grands noms du tennis
mais ce soir nous allons essayer de nous
intéresser au cas d'un petit joueur qui
a réussi à se faufiler au travers des
mailles de la qualification pour accéder
au premier tour des internationaux de
france
son nom régis brunet 23 ans 16e joueur
français
plus d'un million de français en 79
atteint par la folie du tennis une
véritable fièvre blanche dont le sommet
est le rendez vous annuel de roland
garros l'on se presse se compressent
même pour applaudir certains des 128
joueurs du tableau final
mais pour 16 d'entre eux les petits
entre guillemets
roland garros c'est la super aventure
l'espoir passer un ou deux tours et le
rêve des mesures et d'accrocher un bord
vous un conan faire parler de soi
pourquoi pas souvent on est un peu dans
l'anonymat
et heureusement qu'il a roland garros
qui nous sert de temps en temps à faire
de bons résultats ou se faire connaître
un petit peu alors disons le 200e
mondial peut vivre du tennis
or en france on est en france je pense
qu'il peut vivre célibataire d'abord et
sans faire trop d'excès au feu vif
numéro 16 foncé et 280e joueur mondial
régis brunet vie en effet grâce au
tennis mais ces prix remportés dans des
tournois n'ont rien de comparable on
imagine avec les 20 millions de centimes
qui reviendront vainqueur de roland
garros
de plus régis participent à des stages
de tennis et il est sous contrat avec
des marques ce qui lui permet de vivre
comme un cadre moyen
après des qualifications réussies enfin
admis dans le saint des saints
un premier tour difficile 3 sets à 0 le
rêve se brise égalité
régis déçu j'imagine oui déçu surtout
que je pensais pouvoir faire sur
troisième set où j'ai eu six balles de
set
et c'est toujours on sait jamais ce qui
peut se passer après alors ça m'a fait
un peu mal au coeur de pirate ce set
roland garros 79 et terminé à quand le
prochain tournoi l'an prochain
roland-garros soit 80 ben ouais toute
façon n'y a aucun problème pour moi
c'est un tournoi primordiale celle salle
nationale c'est ces deux tournois où il
faut brouiller autour des chiffres
maintenant et tout d'abord les
pronostics depuis à brest pour le tiercé
de main qui se déroulera à chantilly
dans le prix des belles filles elles
mirali 9 majority le 3 vaucouleurs le
six chorales dans le set golden bible 4
anas al ain donné galles 15 la concorde
le 17
d'autres chiffres maintenant avec les
résultats du loto pour gagner il fallait
jouer les numéros suivants que vous
allez voir découvrir sur votre antenne
d'être écrans le 8 le 15 et le 19 le 43
le 44 et le 48 comme numéro
complémentaire il fallait jouer le 42
la petite fiancée du monde n'est plus
mary pickford de l'une des plus grandes
stars du cinéma muet américain est morte
hier soir à l'âge de 86 ans celle qui
fut pendant 15 ans les pouces d'un autre
grand du cinéma
douglas fairbanks que nous voyons ici
avec son épouse donc et charlie chaplin
au milieu vous le voyez signer le fameux
contrat qui devait faire d'eux les
principaux associés des fameux youn est
un artiste les artistes associés elle
avait régné sur le septième art
essentiellement jusqu'à l'avènement du
cinéma par la mary pickford
la météo maintenant avec le temps pour
demain temps frais pour la saison sur la
bretagne la vendée et la basse normandie
sur le reste du pays un temps chaud et
orageux le soleil brillera mais avec un
risque quand même de quelques pluies
d'orage ma tante y voilà ce journal est
maintenant terminée vous avez un dernier
rendez-vous avec l'actualité
le programme avec avec l'aude merci de
votre fidélité à demain